well in cincinnati one bar wants to just  come to you instead  this is cincy bubbles it's a mobile bar  converted from a horse trailer as you do  owner heather vargo is gonna park in  your driveway your street if you live in  cincinnati  and then the party's getting started  vargo says she thought of the idea a few  years ago but the pandemic gave her the  push  she needed to make it reality but the  trailer needed some work  it was a piece of junk when we first got  it my fiance could not see the vision at  all but i  i was just like i see it i see it and  now he's just like fully on board he  loves it he thinks it's amazing  and we're excited well they don't have  their alcohol permit just yet so they're  not  super excited so for now since sea  bubbles is just selling coffee and tea  so  don't book your flights to cincinnati  just yet and get yourself a driveway